hey guys my name is Jess it is the 15th
of februari and did you know the ipod
was released in two thousand and one for
more shitty second-hand pub trivia be
sure to subscribe for now let's do you
first up just when you thought you were
out of Pokemon go they pull you back in
his latest on its most recent update
niantic have announced that 18 new
Pokemon will start appearing in Pokemon
go later this week they will be from
pokemon gold and Silver's Johto region
and will include Chikorita cyndaquil and
totodile the update will also add new
encounter gameplay new evolution items
to new berries and expanded outfit and
accessory options the two new berries
are the NAB ferry which slows the
pokemons movement and the pin up very
which doubles the amount of candy
received if the next catch is successful
niantic CEO John Hanke has also recently
said that the highly anticipated trading
and PvP battle features are coming soon
for all the details on Pokemon goes
latest update check out our story on
gamespot next up PlayStation now is
dumping a bunch of platforms to shift
its focus to PC and ps4 sony has
announced they will be ending support
for the streaming service on ps3
playstation TV sony bravia TV models
dating before 2015 all sony blu-ray
players and all samsung tvs from august
15 ravio TV models from 2016 will only
be supported until april one so that
leaves only ps4 and pc that can access
the service which lets you stream a
massive catalog of ps3 games sony
explained this move puts us in the best
position to grow the service even
further if you use any of the above
devices that we want to give our
heartfelt thanks for your support and we
hope you'll continue with us if you were
using any of those devices or sony
advises you disable auto renewal before
the service ends finally Capcom has
explained why initial shipments for
resident evil 7 will lower than past
games in the series Capcom management
explained a competitive
Resident Evil 6 resident evil 7 initial
3 million in shipments may seem like a
lower initial pace however this can be
attributed to the recent wider adoption
of digital downloads and the transition
from a sharp initial spike in sales for
games to a continuous long tail Rosie
seven chips 2.5 million units in its
launch week and has gone on to ship 3
million units as if every 10 the game is
still 1 million short of Capcom's
initial 4 million unit projection for
this fiscal year capcom explained we
believe that achieving our fiscal year
target of 4 million units for this title
is holding possible as we expect sales
to continue for a longer period hoid on
highly positive post launch reviews from
both the media and consumers that is
everything I got for you today do leave
me your thoughts and feelings in that
comment box head to gamespot for all our
prey coverage and up see you tomorrow